a major abortion case is headed up to
the supreme court and you know what that
means
that means that we are about to get
months and months
of the most vicious and dishonest
arguments
that the left can possibly muster first
up
former u.s senator and current
hysterical crone
claire mccaskill this may end up being
the situation that is often described as
the dog catching the bus
and what happens in america in terms of
the political climate
if in fact this court overturns decades
of precedent
and fails to protect women's
reproductive freedoms um
via this mississippi case and you know i
got to tell you nicole
i don't think younger voters remember
what it was like
before roe v wade i don't think they
realize
that these folks are not going to be
happy until a rape victim
is put in prison for taking the morning
after pill
that's the road they're going down
that's the road they've been trying to
go down for a long time
even though they are really pushing
provisions that are widely rejected by
the vast majority of americans
that's the road that's the road we're
going down right
the jig's up guys all you pro-lifers out
there for decades i felt we made a you
know fairly
persuasive argument that we wanted to
prevent babies from being butchered in
the womb
but i think we need to just be honest
here this is really just about
throwing rape victims in jail for taking
the morning after isn't that
well that's not what we want are you
sure it's
that's just a very very dishonest and
ridiculous way to put it got it i'm
michael knowles it's the michael knowles
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from skidmark who says
masks are perfect because they allow you
to transition seamlessly
from protecting society to burning it
down that's true very few other tools
allow you to be a wonderful hero who
saves grandma from the cough
but then also to become a social justice
warrior
stealing nike sneakers and gucci
handbags for
racial progress or whatever you're doing
that
sort of thing it does not help me sleep
easy
at night it does not when i think of all
the craziness going on out there you
know what does help me sleep easy
my pillow my pillow and actually
speaking of the masks
the mask that i wore for most of the
2020 when we had to wear masks to go
into places was from my pillow it was
made out of the pillow
cases and it actually felt absolutely
fabulous you know how much i love
my pillow it's my favorite part of going
to bed
i go my wife and i fight over are my
pillows well they've done it again
with my slippers the slippers took over
two years to develop
they're designed to wear indoors and
outdoors all day long the my slippers
are made with my pillow foam and impact
gel
to help prevent fatigue made with
quality leather suede
the whole family is going to want them
head on over to mypillow.com
click on the radio listeners square and
use promo code daily wire you will also
get deep discounts on all my pillow
products
including the giza dream bed sheets the
my pillow mattress stopper and my
pillow towel sets or you can call
800-951-7163
and use promo code daily wire
you know that we all love my pillow
because of the politics because they're
pretty conservative
even if they were communists i would i
would i'd buy their products they're
that good
go to mypillow.com right now or you can
call 800-951-7163
i love claire mccaskill's just open
lines she goes
ha you know i don't think young voters
remember what it was like before roe v
wade
what was it like you mean how babies in
in most states at least babies were not
allowed to be just butchered whenever
because that seems perfectly fine that
seems better than the situation we have
now
well no what she's implying she won't
use the number but what she's implying
is that thousands of women were killed
in back alley abortions this was
a canard pushed by the abortion industry
and it's just completely ridiculous you
can look
at the the bureau of justice statistics
you can
you can look at the federal government
uh the
number of women who were killed in
illegal abortions the year before roe
versus wade fewer than 40.
and by the way there were there were a
similar number of women killed from
legal abortions and actually when you
look
at the number of states in which
abortion was legal and illegal
the rate of mortality from those
abortions was
basically the same from legal and
illegal abortions it was very very few
women
so that line goes out the window well
this is about punishing rape victims i
don't see any laws
suggesting we should punish rape victims
i see laws saying we should outlaw
abortion and that there should be
punishments for abortionists
as there obviously should be
why is this coming up now because there
is a mississippi law that would ban
abortions after what is it 15 weeks so
it's that's not even that
crazy i mean that's it's still a lot of
time
but now it's winding its way up to the
supreme court supreme court by the way
which is almost certain to disappoint
supreme court had the chance to undo roe
versus wade in planned parenthood v
casey which is a case i talk about
at some length in my upcoming book
speechless controlling words controlling
minds available now for pre-order and
they didn't do it
and then we keep adding judges we keep
oh now we've got a 6-3 conservative
court is it going to matter i doubt it
i doubt it i don't think they're going
to do anything about it but that doesn't
matter
obviously the abortion issue itself we
could spend a very long time talking
about and perhaps we will as as this
court case gets closer
but what i want to focus in on here are
just the ridiculous arguments
because i'd like to think that i'm i'm
fair i like to think that pro-lifers
generally are fair
to the pro-abortion argument i think the
pro-abortion argument is
that men and women are different and
women can get pregnant and men can't get
pregnant although
actually you're not allowed to say that
anymore and a spanish politician
got in trouble for saying that we'll get
we'll get into that in just a moment
uh but the argument is men can't get
pregnant women can
if you want to have actual equality
between the sexes
then you need to give women the legal
right
to no longer be pregnant to terminate a
pregnancy
and terminating a pregnancy means
killing a little baby and that's pretty
ghastly
but the pro-abortion people will say it
is better for women to have that
autonomy
and that individual liberty is really
licensed but they call it liberty
then then it is to protect the babies i
think that's the argument and naomi wolf
at the time she was a leftist feminist
now i guess she's
kind of moving a little bit more
conservative but for a very long time
she was a prominent leftist feminist
naomi wolf said yes that's the argument
we
need to recognize that the fetus is
human and in all of its humanity we have
to kill it
if we want to have sex equality okay
yeah i get it i get that it's a ghastly
argument i don't think it's persuasive
and i think that's why
the left won't ever make that argument
outright they have to use
phrases like reproductive rights no
one's attacking women's reproductive
rights we're attacking their their
anti-reproductive rights so we're
attacking their
their rights to stop the process of
reproduction namely
to kill the baby that's that's the right
word
because we recognize that the baby's
right to life supersedes
the woman's right to kill the baby or
the abortionist right to kill the baby
or the abortion industry's right to kill
the baby that's the issue here
but because the left can't make that
argument and if if you think there's a
fairer
argument for abortion please bring it to
me send it in i'd be happy to take it up
on the show
but because there isn't one the left
just has to make these disingenuous
arguments so
claire mccaskill says you know all these
women were killed before roe v wages
complete lie
and that you know we want to punish
rape victims or something obviously
complete lie chris cuomo takes it
from the rape angle onto the race angle
he says that pro-lifers
somehow or motivated by racism you would
think
we would have empaneled experts on a
special commission by now to see what
the science says right but we don't seem
to have the intellectual curiosity
about this issue because it's not really
about science
it has become a culture war it's a
political lever to use
as a distraction from policy and solving
problems
to allow people to get up in their
religion and their righteousness
over any sense of what science suggests
but again it's not about science or
consensus it's about dividing lines
legislating to the far right white
freight vote flooding the zone with 536
bills that abridge a woman's right to
control her own body
in 46 states it's just
like voting rights in one way
why are all leftists
slam poets why do they the far right
white fright vote
wow that was great chris or or anthony
kennedy and in
actually on the same issue in planned
parenthood v casey people have the right
to define their own conception
of existence the sweet mystery of life
and then actually the same justice
kennedy in the obergefell decision
we have a right to intimacy what are you
talking about dude
so what chris cuomo says here he says
get your religion
out of this we need to find out what
science says
all hail the great gods science this
issue isn't being discussed in a
scientific way with the experts you're
right
because you're stupid religion isn't
going to decide this for us either
and your experts your high priests of
scientism
don't have any right to to do that we we
of course
should not empanel experts to decide a
fundamental question of our politics
we have we have self-government at least
we have the the appearance of
self-government the facade of
self-government we actually have
technocratic secular progressivism but
according to the constitution we're
supposed to have self-government and in
self-government you don't just empanel
experts to go to the oracle of science
at delphi and have them
tell you what what you're supposed to do
on the question of life
it isn't a scientific question we know
the science we know that a baby's a baby
dum-dum
you know i don't know who else to put it
i'm sorry to be insulting but that
it's not a complicated scientific
question
but having settled the science i'm
willing to go even further left
maybe than chris cuomo will admit we
know the science is the baby's a baby
but there is a political question should
you be able to kill the baby
for some conception of sex equality
as naomi wolf says should you be able to
kill the baby in all his humanity
to make women appear to be more like men
because women can get pregnant and men
can't i don't think you should
but even if chris cuomo does think that
you should
that's not a that's not a scientific
question in this very narrow sense of
science
as a as the method of material inquiry
that's a political and philosophical and
ethical and yes chris
religious question because it gets down
to the question of what
are we what is a human being do we have
any kind of dignity
are we made in the image of god if so
then that implies certain things
that's why we don't that's why we have
laws against murder that's why we have
due process that's why we have
civilization that's why we treat one
another with respect
if we're not if we're just bags of flesh
and really there's no difference between
me and my microphone right now
we're all just stuff then yeah there's
no reason that you shouldn't be able to
kill a baby but there's no reason that
you shouldn't be able to kill anyone
else on the street either
so yes there are there absolutely is a
religious aspect to this
question but these people just can't
get it and actually the reason he brings
in race here i know it seems like a
non-sequitur when he says it's the white
fright light bite sippity boop bop bite
the reason he brings up race in this
question has nothing to do with race
actually the only way that it has to do
with race is that many more black babies
are killed through abortion
so the pro-lifers if anything are
fighting for racial justice but
i'm sure that point is lost on him the
reason he brings up race is because
in the left's very shallow understanding
of ethics and morality
race is racism is the only bad thing
and the physical is the only only thing
that they can quite grasp
so we have to take sin
fallenness or broken human nature and
just reduce it to okay skin color
white supremacy racism bad so any any
bad thing has to be
racist doesn't make a lot of sense
it's not you know things run deeper than
just the skin
but if you want your skin to be feeling
really good if you want to feel hydrated
i would strongly recommend checking out
liquid iv
when you push your body hard when you
just feel run down it's extremely
important to stay hydrated
making hydration a priority helps us
feel healthier on a day-to-day
basis some people need to be hydrated
because they're working out and
exercising
some of us maybe it's because we went
out with the boys and had a couple
coca-colas the night before and now
we're paying for it well liquid iv
can provide two to three times more
hydration than water alone
made with clean ingredients non-gmo
vegan free of gluten dairy and soy it's
the perfect balance
to help you hydrate more quickly and
effectively than water
alone go check these guys out it's
really really great stuff every time
we get a shipment of liquid iv in the
producers steal all of them
so i can i try to steal my favorite
flavors you know but
they they will just take all of them
that's how popular they are head on over
you get liquid iv in bulk nationwide at
costco or you can get 25
off when you go to liquidive.com and use
code michael at checkout
25 off anything you order when you get
better hydration today using promo code
michael
m-i-c-h-a-e-l at liquidity.com
so you have chris cuomo pushing
racial beat poetry on cnn and then
you've got
tweedledum over there the the other side
of the coin
on cnn uh also pushing these racial
issues but he wants to counteract
a a republican talking point
a conservative right-wing boogeyman
you've heard about it you've heard about
it on this
show critical race theory and
don lemon he's gonna debunk critical
race theory with facts and logic okay
that's the plan
take it away don you've probably heard
the attacks on critical
race theory but what exactly is it and
why are some people so
opposed to it here's cnn's jason carroll
critical race theory is a marxist
doctrine
that rejects the vision of martin luther
king jr absolutely
false it's basically teaching kids to
hate our country
and to hate each other based on race
false
and slanderous meet professor and
scholar
kimberly crenshaw crenshaw is one of the
founders of critical race theory
to be clear critical race theory does
not say someone is racist because of the
color of their skin
and it does not say anyone should be
ashamed of themselves
because of the color of their skin it is
quote rooted in critical race theory
which
is rooted in marxism rooted in marxism
why is this so triggering for them
why is this so triggering why come on
why why why
it it is very difficult
to succinctly go through every single
false statement they made there
because it's basically the totality
of the segment so let's just begin
where we left off don lemon laughing at
this idea that critical race theory is
rooted in marxism
critical race theory derives from
critical theory critical theory is a
much broader
pseudo-academic discipline it was
developed in the 1930s
critical race theory is one of the
derivations of that pushed
largely by kimberly crenshaw as being
extraordinarily dishonest in that clip
you'll notice she says
it's false what trump said is false what
desantis said is false but she doesn't
quite explain how it's false
even as she goes on she never addresses
quite how it's false
critical race theory comes from critical
theory critical theory was developed by
the frankfurt school
in the 1930s the frankfurt school was a
group of marxist intellectuals and you
don't need to take my word for it you
can read it in their writings but you
don't even need to read it in their
writings because the frankfurt school
was initially called the institute for
marxism and then they left
germany they come to the united states
they push this at this discipline
the discipline is predicated on a line
from marx
a line that marx wrote to ruga which is
that he called for the ruthless
criticism of all that exists and the
critical theorists came out and said
okay we're going to apply this critical
lens
to all of society and the purpose for
this
was to attain what another
neo-marxist scholar antonio gramsci
called uh cultural hegemony
to to crack the common sense because the
ordinary people you know the the
proletariat the workers of the world
that were supposed to unite in the
marxian revolution
did not unite because they didn't care
very much for leftist theories because
they liked their traditions and their
way of life
and the critical theorists said okay
well if if we want to be able to
crack all of that we need to apply a
ruthlessly critical lens
to that ordinary wavelength so obviously
it is marxist i don't know
don lemon probably doesn't know that but
if he doesn't know that then he's being
extraordinarily dishonest
to give kim crenshaw credit here what
she said was
no critical race theory doesn't say that
you're racist because of the color of
your skin
and it it does it does say that but i
guess
the way she can get away with what she
said is critical race theory just says
that
everything is racist everything and she
later even sort of admits this she says
you know the systems are racist the
institutions are racist okay well if
everything's racist and we are all
steeped in this racism and the racism
is white supremacy then yes certainly
one is
racist by virtue of the color of one's
skin or rather just by existing
it's not even just that white people are
racist it's that everybody
in some ways pushes anti-black racism
which she believes
is the foundation of the country and so
if the
if the heart of the country if the
beating heart of the united states and
the civilization
is evil and wicked what does that imply
doesn't take a genius to say
you've got to rip it down and you've got
to start over and you've got to burn it
to the ground like blm did
for six months last year
i don't understand how this wasn't a
refutation of critical race theory
in any way don lemon just had people
standing very seriously and said this
critical race theory isn't bad but i
can't tell what is it is
is the argument that critical race
theory is not being taught in schools or
is the argument that critical race
theory is not
a marxist radical ideology seeking to
upend the country
or are you are you granting that second
part but you're saying that's actually a
good thing i think it's the latter i
think it's
the third version of that which is yeah
critical race theory is exactly what
republicans are saying that it is but
that's good
right because they're the ones saying
yeah we should pull down statues of not
just robert e lee but thomas jefferson
yeah we should get rid of our traditions
in this country
yeah the history of the country is
horrible we need
we need a revolution we need in the
words of barack obama we need to
fundamentally
transform america michael
did you bring up barack obama you can't
that's racist to criticize barack obama
that's a real that's a real point that
the left makes they say
that it is racist to oppose barack obama
and they didn't just say that during the
heat of the 2008 campaign
another knucklehead on cnn fareed
zakaria
came out just yesterday and said that
gop
opposition to barack obama the
conservative opposition to the most
leftist president
from at least wilson up until his time
and and probably including wilson was
solely based on racism
it was of course race the issue that
republicans had happily exploited
that would finally push the party to the
edge
a black president in the white house
triggered a dramatic response
afro-leninism coming to you on a silver
platter
barack hussein obama the rise of the tea
party movement
was supposed to be a response to
obamacare
but in reality it was mostly a response
to obama's race obama's election was a
trigger
this president i think has exposed
himself as a guy
over and over and over again who has a
deep seated hatred
for white people
the base began not only to hate obama
what is wrong with this president but to
despise
gop leaders for being unable to stop him
yeah yeah i that that's it right
it's not it had nothing to do with
barack obama
saying that he wanted to fundamentally
transform the country
which is an admission that he hates the
country you don't
fundamentally transform things that you
love when you're lying next to your
sweetie at night
you don't say honey hey sweetheart i
can't wait to fundamentally transform
you you don't do that
you you want to keep things that you
love
basically as they are maybe improve them
here or there but you know you love them
if you want to fundamentally change it
you don't love it when michelle obama
comes out and says the first time she
was ever proud of her country as an
adult
was when it elected her husband that
reveals an antipathy for the country
when barack obama comes in and says
we're going to transform education we're
going to transform energy
we're going gonna we're gonna save the
planet my election is gonna save the
planet
that's how transformative it's going to
be that put a lot of people
on edge i mean the tea party for
goodness sakes it's funny in that first
clip there they said it's about white
men
and if you look there were i don't know
there were about five or six people in
the in the frame
but one of them is obviously not a white
guy and so they got off that frame
really quickly i guess they couldn't
find a totally white one and then they
go on and they show you know some
somebody i guess making some comment
about afro something or other and so
they're saying
it's all about race i was at a ton of
tea party rallies in 2010 2009 that era
my complaint about the tea party is that
it was
so focused on economic issues
i actually wish it were based more on
cultural issues
issues like immigration issues like even
pro-life issues like the defense of
marriage but it was it was a
very very narrowly economic movement it
was against obamacare
and then it it was also it also opposed
the
deficit spending which is important
obviously you got to focus on that a
little bit too
focused on jobs it just it's an
alternate reality that cnn is presenting
here and the reason they're doing it
is they have no arguments against
the conservatives other than to malign
us as you know vicious
misogynists racists or whatever and i'm
not even saying that you can't
if you're going to make the accusation
you should at least defend it but
if you've got a real problem with what
the gop is doing
i think it would behoove you to make
to attack the strongest argument that
the gop is making
that's what that is what i try to do on
this show maybe i don't always succeed
but i do think
that i am attacking the best arguments
that the left is making
or the honest arguments that the left
doesn't want to make but they don't do
that for us because i guess they just
don't have an answer for it
the masks are coming off that's what i
think
that's what ben's talking about today
he's going to talk about the public
health pseudo experts i'll also talk a
little bit
about israel it's hard to talk at all
these days
because the politically correct woke
culture
has left us all speechless which is the
title of my upcoming book head on over
to speechlessbook.com
to pre-order your copy today or
if you want an extra special personal
touch you can text
speechless to 53445 to pre-order a
signed copy
do not wait pre-order your copy today
understand the pc police better than
they
understand themselves understand where
the conservatives went wrong
and how we can turn it around before
it's too late what's the name of that
book
speechless where's the bill
there it is okay good speechlessbook.com
we'll be right back with a lot more
joe rogan he's getting into dangerous
territory
joe rogan who was a bernie bro right
he's not exactly a rock-ribbed
conservative
but he's seeing what we're all seeing
he's seeing
that in the world of critical race
theory and intersectionality and woke
politics and a racial caste system being
voiced by the left
we are increasingly living in a world in
which
straight white dudes are not allowed to
talk
joe i think you made the point
beautifully you can never be woken up
that's the problem it keeps going
it keeps going further and further and
further down the line and if you get
to the point where you capitulate where
you
agree to all these demands it will
eventually get to
straight white men are not allowed to
talk right because it's your privilege
to express yourself when
other people of color have been silenced
throughout history it will be
you're not allowed to go outside because
so many people were imprisoned for so
many years i mean i'm not joking no i
know i know it really will get there
it's that crazy you know we just got to
be nice to each other man
and there's a lot of people that are
taking advantage
of this weirdness in our culture and
then that becomes
their thing their thing is calling
people out for their privilege calling
people
out for their position he's obviously
right i mean we're already told this
we we are already told that certain
people are not allowed that uh
it's not just certain people straight
white men are not allowed to voice their
opinion
on certain issues and it goes back
further even than the woke blm craziness
goes back on the issue of abortion we're
told men are not allowed to have an
opinion on abortion
i'm pretty sure they are first of all
very often it's men who
state that opinion and they say oh you
know i'm a liberal man and i think that
men
should just be quiet about abortion like
okay buddy take your own advice and shut
up then
because i do have here's my here's my
crazy outrageous
patriarchal opinion uh
killing babies is bad it's bad it's
always bad and you shouldn't do it ever
even if it's like a crying baby even
even if that baby you know is
kind of sometimes you know it's four in
the morning you hear that baby crying
well
even then that's my opinion i
am a human being i have faculties of
reason
i am a citizen of this country i
participate in the body politic
and so yeah i'm allowed to have that
opinion i'm allowed to voice it
and frankly that opinion should carry
the day and everybody else should listen
to that opinion and recognize that that
is the correct opinion
okay but we're told no you're not
allowed to have that opinion we're
increasingly told
that a white people specifically white
men are not allowed
to voice an opinion on blm or police
brutality or whatever because we have
not had the lived experience
of whatever you know people who who have
experienced the cops pulling them over
by the way i've been pulled over by cops
plenty of times because i have a little
bit of a lead foot
but no it doesn't matter well my skin is
kind of swarthy it doesn't matter not
swirly enough
you don't have the lived experience and
of course at the heart of this is a
radical subjectivism
which says you don't have faculties of
reason actually critical race theory
says this
you don't have faculties of reason you
can't rely on them you can't know
anything about the objective world all
you can know
is the reality of your own subjective
suffering
and by the way you white guys have never
suffered
well how do you know about the reality
of my subjective suffering if you're
telling me we can't okay you can know
but i can't know okay
understood we are already being told
this sort of thing
and there's another irony here we're
told that white supremacy pervades the
whole
country and it's based on white
supremacy pew research did a
survey a couple years back of racial
consciousness
asked people how how important is your
race to your identity
for every racial group other than white
people
most respondents said that race is
either very
or extremely important to their sense of
identity
for white people the number was 15
so you've got you've got at least some
somewhat important you know you've got
some level of importance 50
of every other racial group except for
white white people have the lowest
racial identity by far of anybody
in the country which is why we're so
shocked and that's why
we get offended when they call us racist
but it's
as joe rogan is saying here it's just an
exploitation
it's an emotional sort of exploitation
we're talking a lot about immunity and
inoculations and things these days
i am pleased to report that i am
completely immune to white guilt i just
don't feel it it's not i'm immune to
male
guilt i'm pretty soon we're gonna have
straight guilt i'm immune to that too i
just don't feel it
if you do feel that in any way it is
because
you are buying into the leftist vision
of the world
which is perverse and anti-historical
and wicked
and wrong and you just gotta get shut of
it lose it throw it out the window
and things will make a bit more sense
twitter approved joe rogan right this
week when
twitter suspended a spanish politician
for pointing out that men
cannot get pregnant we were talking
about this earlier because
because the the actual strong or strong
i put in in quotes
the strong argument for abortion is that
men and women are different because
because only women can get pregnant they
should be able to kill their kids that's
that's it that's what it comes down to
right and uh but that argument requires
the acknowledgement that men can't get
pregnant but then
the transgender ideology
demands that we pretend that men can get
pregnant so anyway
this spanish politician his name is
francisco jose contrera
he's the deputy leader of vox which is a
right-wing party in the country
he said that a man cannot get pregnant a
man has no uterus or eggs
and twitter suspended him for 12 hours
because of hateful conduct
he's a white man he's not you know a
little swarthy like me
but not allowed to make just a perfectly
obvious
statement of fact because when that
reality
contradicts the delusions of the leftist
worldview
the leftist worldview will win out
why because the left has engaged through
the machinations
of the western marxists the
intellectuals who led to political
correctness and wokeness and cancer
culture and the war of position
that the brilliant communist theorist
antonio gramsci called 400 years ago
because that has worked it's worked very
well and they've attained positions of
influence
they're able to exercise that those
levers of power
there's a flip side to this though we're
told that if you do not tell
a little girl that she's a little boy
that you're hateful you're bigoted
you're awful you're terrible you're
harming
her you're probably going to kill her
she's probably going to commit suicide
you awful bigot you know there's a flip
side to this story though
as these perverts in the mainstream
media and in politics
and in education are convincing little
kids to castrate themselves and to pump
themselves full of cross-sex hormones
and people are transitioning through
this social contagion
there's an increasing number of people
who are detransitioning
because they realize that these sickos
these psychos have gotten them to
mutilate their bodies
against their own best interests there
was a tick tock going around so much
of the trans ideology gets spread on
tick-tock
it's really short quippy videos that
very often leftist teenagers and young
adults
will just spout nonsense on well this
was the best tick tock i ever saw
it looks like a young man is in the
frame
you know you're kind of like a scrawny
young man but still a young man
and he says hi i've gone by the name
matthew matt for the past three years
he's shaving in the window right
but a few weeks ago i found god again
okay he hit me out of left field and
completely rocked my world
peep the cool hair my bff did for me
it's like a cross on the back god
reminded me of his love for me
the love i had lost sight of through the
years now he's putting makeup on i
started to see things in a new light
things i hadn't thought about
now you realize wait a second he might
not be a he
a little makeup on the eyes then he knit
me together in my mother's womb
exactly the way he wanted me to be
referring to god and because of this
realization i'm de-transitioning and
re-transitioning
into the woman that god intended for me
to be feels weird i'm excited for this
new journey a little anxious too
but through my anxiety i know i have god
by my side
and then you see it's a girl it's a girl
sitting there
pretty girl that's a great feeling
wow isn't that great this is a feel-good
video
this is you actually get a little choked
up about it
because you you see this
person who looks somewhat androgynous in
the beginning of the video
very shortly cropped hair you know
men's clothing no makeup and
not really smiling sort of shaving even
though there's no hair to shave and then
by the end you see oh someone with
makeup looks more like a girl
so it's it is a gen it's a gender
transition just like the left tells us
we should be able to do and yet the left
will not applaud that video
we are told that you should be able to
change your sex however however you
please but something tells me
they're not going to applaud that idea
that a girl
who believed for some period that she
was like a boy you know a tomboy or
something or a little more masculine
that that girl would then recognize that
wait a second
god did make me how how he wanted to
make me
but actually i am who i am i am a girl i
am
even though maybe i this is a fallen
world so i felt a little weird but i i
am actually a girl this this argument
you sometimes hear
god doesn't make mistakes this was an
argument in the gay rights movement
decades ago and now it's an argument in
the transgender
movement but it doesn't quite work as
well in the transgender movement right
because if you say
okay god doesn't make mistakes right
you're a girl
well no but i think i'm a boy right but
god doesn't make mistakes
now i don't think that the god doesn't
make mistakes is
natural exactly the best argument in a
fallen world because the fact is that
sin and death pervade the world because
of original sin
but if you're going to use that argument
it surely does not work
on this transgender issue
i suspect you're going to see more of
this and i suspect for any parents out
there
who are or teachers out there who are
supporting this
vicious evil ideology of transgenderism
which is
just a rehashing of the same old
gnostic heresies that you saw in
manichaeism that you saw albigensianism
these on marcianism
there are a lot a lot of isms here folks
going back thousands of years
it's not as the i know that we like to
think in this modern world that we're
the first people to ever think of
anything but we're not these
smarter people than you and i have
hashed out these ideas before
but because our education is so degraded
now we we
do not really have the access to to
these thoughts before we make big
mistakes
i think you're going to see a lot of
this and i think you're going to see a
lot of resentment
from people who were pushed by perverts
and idiots
into mutilating and destroying their
bodies at a very young age
below the age of consent before they had
developed their faculties of reason
and woe to the parents and the educators
who indulge this kind of insanity young
girls fall for this nonsense because
the media push radical propaganda
among other the educators as well the
politics as well
there's been a lot of talk over the past
few days
over israel's decision to blow up that
associated press building
in the gaza strip now i've told you i'm
going to refrain from making jokes
about a government blowing up a press
building because you know look we
support freedom of the press
and journalism and the great heroes okay
okay sure i'm not even being
particularly facetious but
this does raise a question
if the associated press is just a
journalistic outlet and they're the
defenders of the free government the
free world and democracy dies in
darkness
why were they sharing a building with
hamas why were they sharing a building
with a terrorist organization tom cotton
senator cotton asked that very question
just yesterday
i must observe why is the associated
press sharing a building
with hamas surely these intrepid
reporters
knew who their neighbors were they
knowingly allow themselves
to be used as human shields by a u.s
designated
terrorist organization did the ap
pull its punches and declined a report
for years
on hamas's misdeeds
i submit that the ap has some
uncomfortable questions
to answer yet the ap and its fellow
journalists are in high dodging
about israel's holy appropriate
airstrike
leave it to whiny reporters
to make themselves the story and the
victim
when terrorists are shooting missiles at
innocent civilians such a great point
because what you see senator cotton does
here is he undercuts the ap's
only defense the only defense the ip can
make here is well we didn't know
they could just play dumb right they say
what do you i had no idea that hamas was
running a major operation out of our
building
now for other organizations playing dumb
in this regard might work if if israel
blew up the ice cream shop building they
could say we didn't know
hamas was in here if they if they blew
up i don't know the
book publishers or if they blew up the
tire store oh we didn't no come on
but if you blow up the reporters
if you blow up the journalists if you
vote the people who say that they're the
greatest investigators sniffing out
truth and their greatest defenses yeah
we had no idea terrorists were two
floors down
well then you say well you don't sound
like particularly good journalists do
you
but obviously the ap new there is no
question in my mind
i don't have the i don't have the
evidence but i got a lot of
circumstantial evidence
of course the ap knew but they were
cozying up
of course they knew hamas they were the
sources for goodness sakes
there's a bigger question why did the ap
even have an office in gaza
because our intrepid journalists
the fourth estate the objective
reporters
are pushing propaganda
it's not just the associated press
that's pushing
propaganda from enemies of our allies
and of our country
bloomberg mike bloomberg the former
future president remember mike bloomberg
mayor of new york zillionaire
financial media mogul and media mogul
more broadly
it is now being reported by breitbart
alex marlow breitbart
has just written a book about this uh
bloomberg and his
uh top associates at his news
conglomerate bloomberg lp
have regularly met in recent years in
beijing
with top chinese communist party
officials now this is according to the
chinese government just a little bit to
give you a sense of the timeline
august 19 2015 bloomberg mike himself
the man
meets with zhang jiang who's the
director of the state council
information office
and deputy director of the publicity
department of the communist party of
china so we're talking about the actual
propaganda leaders
in the country he meets with them
to discuss quote international exchange
and cooperation in the field of media
later on a few months later bloomberg lp
global exec
vp kevin sheeky meets with zhang as well
as zhang fuhai
who are the director general and deputy
director general
of the scio internet affairs bureau so
the propaganda
arm here specifically on the internet
ashiki then became mike bloomberg's
campaign manager for that ill-fated
2020 presidential run many many many
meetings over the years
this is not low-level staffers this is
not just meeting with
apparatchiks from the chinese government
to facilitate
certain corporate access or business
deals this is
the heads of the media group meeting
with
the heads of china's propaganda industry
that is the kind of intrepid
wonderful objective hard-hitting speak
truth to power reporting
that we're getting from one of the
largest media organizations in the world
from bloomberg
why do we believe this stuff why do we
take this seriously
there there are alternative media
if you're listening to this program
obviously you're tuning in to some
alternative media
and the alternative media do fairly well
you know every so ev every
news cycle or so you'll find that
right wing media daily wire or dan
bongino or a few other people
they do well on facebook according to
certain metrics according to other
metrics not really but according to some
you know we'll get stories that get
shared or something so you say
okay there's no big deal the left
they've got their media and they meet
with the
chinese communist party and the right
we've got our media and we post some
stories to facebook so come on it's the
same thing
even if even if the daily wire
is the top performer ever of all time on
facebook
which it's not but we still do very well
on facebook
that's one outlet dan bongino okay it's
two outlets
two relatively small outlets compared to
nbc abc cbs the washington post
the associated press cnn msnbc
the new york times the la times
the on and on and on npr
pbs on and on and on
there's no comparison
we we think we're doing great over here
we love we got all our great
listeners we got all our great readers
yeah we're doing great in conservative
media
but the left controls the media
and they're pushing a lot of very
harmful propaganda
speaking of propaganda i think while the
media establishment
are doing a good job for the dems biden
himself not doing a great job
biden has a message now okay it's a
message
about how to break out of the lockdowns
and the message is simple
vax or mask it's vaxxed
or masked that's it that's the whole
video faxed
or masked is that does that rhyme
no no it's it's actually it's like a
almost a near rhyme so it's even
kind of weirder and more annoying what
does that mean vaxxed or masked i'm
neither right now and i feel great i've
been neither for
the whole time and i i feel awesome this
reminds me of when puff daddy did that
stupid vote or die thing
i was like vote or die you got vote
or die um
i'm pretty sure there's a third option
unless you're unless this is a criminal
threat
i what if i just do neither what if i
just hang out is that cool
vaxxed or mask or die or vote
no not not very persuasive not
persuading a whole lot of americans
by the way by the way our other
propaganda minister here in the united
states dr fauci
has come out and admitted once again
that he lied
admitted once again that he misled the
american people remember we were told
you by dr fauci you have to wear the
masks even after you're vaccinated you
have to do it you say well what
what's the point of getting the vaccine
if i have to wear the masks after no you
have to
and then they realized no one was going
to get the vaccine because if your
life's not going to change why would i
shoot myself full of this
hastily developed inoculation if i don't
even get any if i don't get any
political benefit for it
and he says okay actually you can take
the mask off you just ask well what
happened here he said well it's
basically political theater
i'm obviously careful because i mean i'm
a physician and a healthcare provider i
am now much more comfortable in in
people seeing me indoors without a mask
i mean
before the cdc made the recommendation
change
i didn't want to look like i was giving
mixed signals but being a fully
vaccinated person
the chances of my getting infected in an
indoor setting is extremely low and
that's the reason why in indoor settings
now
i feel comfortable about not wearing a
mask because i'm fully man i'm fully
vaccinated
yes i wore the mask and also told all
you stupid sheep to wear the mask
even though i knew you didn't have to
and it was total nonsense
because i wanted to shill for the cdc
because i'm a doctor i'm a doctor when
was the last time dr fauci saw a patient
how many patients does this guy see a
week he's not a doctor he's a politician
who has medical expertise but he's a
politician
political theater so if he's thrown away
his credibility
why should we believe him why should we
follow these guys
the associated press paling around with
terrorists
why should we listen to them
the leftists on cnn
are arguing against positions that we do
not hold
in very often just spreading outright
lies like don lemon did on
critical race theory why should we
listen to them why do they have any
authority leftist politicians claire
mccaskill
saying that we just want to punish rape
victims or something why did we listen
to this why
we have no obligation to engage in a bad
faith
debate we have no obligation to pay any
heed to people
who have acknowledged their own bad
faith and squandered their credibility
like the fouchies of the world and the
other technocrats none i know
there's something about the conservative
movement quote unquote of the last 20
years where you think no we just
we've got the free marketplace of ideas
and we've got to engage in the ideas
we'll always win no we have no
there's no reason whatsoever to deal on
the level with people who are acting in
bad faith
not a chance uh of show me the good
faith argument please show me one
and i'd love to engage with it but other
than that if assuming you can't
we need to exercise our political power
i'm michael nolan's the michael knowles
show i'll see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
board
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nikka geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 today on the
ben shapiro show public health pseudo
experts and their political allies are
unmasked as the real science deniers the
andrew brown case comes apart
and the radical left's mask comes off
when it comes to winking and
anti-semitism
that's today on the bench bureau show
give it a listen